-Hello and welcome,
welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome. Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, last night,
President Biden hosted
the president of South Korea
for a White House state dinner.
And the South Korean president
actually sang a rendition
of his favorite song.
Watch this.
-♪ A long, long time ago ♪
♪ I can still remember how that
music used to make me smile ♪
♪ Something touched me deep
inside the day the music died ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
-Wow! That's actually...
There's always that
one friend at karaoke
who knows they're good,
you know?
"I don't need the lyrics.
I don't need the..."
♪ Don't stop, belie-- ♪
Meanwhile, this morning,
the president of South Korea
woke up like,
"I did what last night?
Honey, you got to get me out
of there when I get like that."
You know, this actually
reminds me of the time
another world leader
did something similar.
-Mommy don't know
that daddy's getting hot.
At the body shop.
Doing something unholy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Remember that?
-Ike?!
-Meanwhile, yesterday,
Biden told reporters that
before he decided to run
for re-election,
he took a hard look
at his age.
Is it me or does Biden
always look like
he's taking a hard look?
You know, he's always like...
Then Biden reminded everyone
that he's the same age
as Lincoln...if he
were still alive today.
Some more news from
The White House.
Today, for
Take Your Child to Work Day,
Biden held an event
with his staffers' kids.
Yep, Biden spent time with
White House staffers' kids.
He even took
some questions from them.
Let's see how that went.
-One granddaughter lives
in -- in Pennsylvania,
in Philadelphia.
One granddaughter
lives in New York.
lives in Washington.
One granddaughter
lives in Wilmington.
My grandson lives in California.
I left somebody out, didn't I?
Anyway...
I did say five. You're right.
So, let me see.
I got two in Philadelphia.
They're confusing me.
But they're all around.
[ Laughter ]
-The kid was like,
"You might want to take
a harder look
at that age thing, you know?"
Then Biden looked
at the kid like,
"Hey, what is this?
'Meet the Press'?
Cut me some slack."
You know you only said five?
Anyway, long story short,
that kid's parent was fired.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I got one grandkid who lives
in Pennsylvania.
One..."
My goodness.
Other kids are like,
"Hey, come on.
We got questions, too, man.
What's your favorite ice cream?!
Come on!"
You guys see this?
Last night, Tucker Carlson
posted a video on Twitter
where he spoke out
for the first time
since his exit from Fox News.
Take a look at this.
-One of the first things
you realize
when you step
outside the noise for a few days
is how many genuinely
nice people there are.
The other thing you notice
when you take a little time off
is how unbelievably stupid
most of the debates you see
on television are.
-Yeah. Nothing says
"I landed on my feet"
like ranting
in a decommissioned sauna.
He stood up,
he's wearing a towel.
He's like, "Alright."
Yep, Tucker criticized
the current state of debate
on television, then said,
"And that's why
I chose to be fired."
I heard that, next month,
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
plans to launch his
2024 presidential campaign.
Which makes sense because,
already, his campaign
slogan is "Mayday, Mayday."
Yeah, DeSantis is having
a tough time.
It's hard to say you'd work
well with other countries
when you can't even
get along with Epcot.
You know what I'm saying?
Speaking of Disney,
this is going viral.
Disney released posters
for each character
in their new live-action
"Little Mermaid" movie,
and people think Flounder
looks a little too realistic.
Check it out.
Here's the original Flounder.
Now here's the new one.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I guess Disney wants
all the ocean characters
to be super-accurate.
I mean, look at this teaser
I saw.
-The Magical World of Disney
invites you under the sea,
where you'll meet
Sebastian, Scuttle,
flounder, and an
all-new ocean character,
Dirk.
-[ Coughs ]
-The [bleep] you looking at?
-Wow! That is real.
-Wow!
-Hey, I read that,
according to a sleep expert,
if you want
a good night's rest,
your bedroom should be
stark and bare.
Yep. So, apparently, the best
place to sleep is
Bed Bath & Beyond.
Oh!
-Oh, hey! Oh!
Hey! Hey!
-Wow!
-Oh, hey! Hey!
-Finally, guys, I was
watching TV the other day.
I was just flipping
through the channels
and I came across
this show on TeenNick.
It's called "Ew!"
And it's a pretty good show.
And a lot of people say that
I look like the main character.
I don't know
if I see it, though.
But, anyways, here,
look for yourselves.
Here's the latest
episode of "Ew!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi, everyone!
Welcome to "Ew!"
My name is Sara.
And if you're wondering,
that's S-A-R-A with no "H,"
because H's are ew!
Joining me today is the
new foreign exchange student
who just moved in across
the street, Bjergen Kjergen.
Hi, Bjergen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Swedish accent ] Hi!
-Hi. How's it going?
-Pretty good, yeah.
It's great to be on you.
-Yeah. I love your pigtails.
Did you braid them yourself?
-No. They were done by
my sisters,
Herdie, Kerdie, and Donna.
-Yeah. Well, they look amazing.
So, Bjergen, are you ready for
the school dance competition
next week?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I'm also a bit nervous,
you know?
I've never danced in front
of other people before.
-Ew! Don't be shy. It's easy.
We can practice
the dance together right now.
I'm going to put it on TikTok.
-♪ You turn me on
like a light switch ♪
♪ When you're movin' your body
around and around ♪
♪ Now, I don't wanna
fight this ♪
♪ You know how to
just make me want ♪
♪ You turn me...♪
-Let's see if it went viral.
It only has seven likes. Ew!
That's not a lot of likes.
-What?
-I said,
it's not a lot of likes.
-Oh! I's not a lot of likes.
-Yeah, yeah.
Anyway, let's play a game.
What's your favorite game,
Bjergen?
-Well, in my country,
we have a game, yeah.
It's called the floor
is a fluva.
-Is that like the floor is lava?
-Yeah, but we
call it a fluva.
-Can two people play
it together?
-Oh, does a pjerp wear a hjerp?
-Yes?
-Yeah. Of course. Let's do it.
-We can put this on TikTok, too!
-Okay.
-Here we go.
-Ready? Yeah.
-Ready? Alright, go.
Here we go.
-Yeah.
Bjergen, the floor is floggon.
The floor is -- I'm gonna go
for the slide tackle.
Oh, my --
-Are you okay?
-What is going on down here?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys doing some parkour?
Hey, check it out.
I got some moves of my own.
365 degrees, 24/7.
-Ew! That's my stepdad, Gary.
Get out of here, Gary!
-Hey, come on. You girls
are making some TikTaks?
Have you seen that new A.I.?
♪ Hash brown like ChatBLT ♪
-Ew!
-Anyway, if you like
cinnamon buns, hun, your mother
and I are upstairs making
some gluten-free pastries.
And this just in --
I have a sensitivity.
♪ If you want a sweet treat
that's safe to eat ♪
♪ You gotta make sure
it doesn't have any wheat ♪
♪ A-take a big bite
and a munch, munch, munch ♪
♪ Pastries for breakfast,
dinner, and snack time ♪
♪ Munch, munchie ♪
♪ Munchie, munch ♪
♪ Munch, munch, munch, munch,
a-muchidy, munch ♪
♪ You spell "munch" backwards,
it still spells "munch" ♪
-Ew! Gary, get out of here!
Come on!
-I had one more.
Catch it on the flippity-flop!
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay, it's time for the "Ew!"
Speed Round, okay? Ready?
-Oh. Okay.
-Here we go.
"Minecraft."
-Ew!
-Jibbitz.
-Capybaras.
-[ Laughs ] Ew!
-Fjallraven backpacks.
-Uh...ew!
My cousin makes those.
[ Laughs ]
-John Leguizamo.
-Cute!
-Wait. Really?
-Yeah! He's, like,
really talented, you know?
Have you ever seen
"To Wong Foo,
Thanks for Everything!
Julie Newmar"?
-"To Wong Foo
Thanks for Everything!
Julie Newmar"?
-Yeah.
-No, never heard of it.
-Oh. Alright.
[ Cellphone chimes ]
-Oh, look.
Bjergen, our dance is getting
a lot of likes.
We're going viral!
-Oh, that's good.
-I'm getting a FaceTime!
From "Spam Likely."
-Oh.
-I'm going to answer it.
-Yeah?
-Hello?
-Hey, Sara. Hey, Bjergen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-O-M-jeans!
It's Charlie Puth!
-Charlie Puth, I love you.
-I just wanted to say
I saw your video.
I love your moves.
So I want to offer you both
front-row tickets
to my next show.
-Front-row seats?!
What is life?! What is life?!
This is crazy!
-Yeah. It's crazy!
-That's all the time
we have for "Ew!"
I want to thank Bjergen
for joining us tonight.
Tune in next week. Ew!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
My thanks to Drew Barrymore
and Charlie Puth.
You can catch him on the
Charlie Live Experience tour
this summer.
Stick around.
When we come back,
we're talking to Drew Barrymore!